they could all be silent spreaders
no symptoms like coughing or fever but
they could well be passing on the
coronavirus
many doctors say only mass testing can
break the chain of transmission
with the increase of cases in the
neighborhood i think it's good for me to
know if i have the virus or not
there's a chance i'm asymptomatic i
don't know that though
i live with my mother who's on dialysis
and of course you don't know if you have
the virus or if you're asymptomatic
but the us centers for disease control
and prevention has changed its testing
guidelines
to exclude people who don't have
symptoms even if they've been recently
exposed to the virus
that's got alarm bells ringing some
experts say many patients appear most
contagious right before the onset of
symptoms
models suggest half all transmissions
can be traced back to people before they
get sick
if they get sick at all well let's talk
about this with
healthcare expert john campbell a
retired nurse and academic who joins us
from
carlisle england john is this change in
cdc guidelines
dangerous well the new york times
certainly seems to think so the new york
times says this was done quietly
and it said it was done to exclude
people who'd been in contact with
symptomatic individuals
but if you actually go to the centers
for disease control website it's
slightly more nuanced than that
it's still advising people with mild
symptoms to be tested
and of course it's still advising
testing for people that are in care
facilities or working
work in hospitals for example what it's
actually saying is people who've been in
close contact
and the defined closed contact is six
feet which of course we would call two
meters
or less for more than 15 minutes what
it's actually saying is they do not
necessarily
need to be tested now they can still be
tested at the discretion of their nurses
or their doctors or their clinicians
or according to local guidelines so it's
actually is a change it's saying it's
not necessarily that they need to be
tested
so it's a bit of a nuanced change there
but i still think it's a problem because
this means we could have people that are
in contact with uh known cases
who could then be developing the disease
and we know that a large
proportion of people are asymptomatic
initially
now about half of those people that are
asymptomatic initially will go on to
become
symptomatic eventually but it's
interesting the latest data is showing
that people are most infectious
immediately before they become
symptomatic and in the first day
after they become symptomatic and of
course the symptoms can start off as
being fairly mild
so what this means is we could have a
lot of people going around who are
shedding large amounts of the virus that
we don't know about
if we don't test them just in case
they've been exposed
i think if i can jump in there you're
talking about a large amount of people
i've i've read studies that show up to
half those infected with covert 19 show
no
or hardly any symptoms doesn't that make
this fight
almost impossible well
it makes it more difficult you're
absolutely right the latest
meta-analysis shows about 40
47 of people might not develop symptoms
but about half of those will go on to
develop symptoms over time
but many will have a mild disease but it
is you're right it's very difficult it's
very hard to fight an invisible enemy
and the only way we can make this enemy
visible is by reporting symptoms
or by testing we need to test people
and as well as that we now know as well
as testing there's various other things
we can test for in the blood to screen
people as well
that it would be a good idea to do
anything we can do to make this virus
more visible
is going to help then we can target our
isolation we can target quarantines
and then we can be much more specific
and targeted in the way we're attacking
this virus
how do we even know how many
asymptomatic people there are out there
if they haven't seen a doctor if we
don't have that medical data if there
aren't
even enough tests to do the mass testing
you're talking about
it's remarkably difficult you can
sometimes you can tell to an extent by
the amount of people that become
symptomatic in the future
and the amount of people that become
hospitalized and even the amount of
people die
but the main way that we do this is with
antigen surveys
now different countries do this in
different ways but in the uk the office
for national statistics
will test about a thousand random
households throughout the country for
the antigen
and because they're testing randomly in
random areas
they can extrapolate that up to the
whole population
so it is quite possible to give fairly
accurate estimates or really very
accurate estimates of how many people in
the community
are infected at any one time and
thankfully in the uk and germany at the
moment that's relatively low
in spain it's much higher and it's also
climbing quite rapidly in france as well
john what about age does it play a role
when it comes to being asymptomatic
um it does it's about 27
of children are genuinely asymptomatic
and only about 16 percent of adults
remain asymptomatic
now many more has to be stressed many
more are asymptomatic for a period of
time
and then become symptomatic but it
remains the case that more children
remain
completely asymptomatic than adults 27
percent of children and about 16 percent
of adults
but just because they're asymptomatic
doesn't mean things are going on in the
body if you do x-rays and ct scans you
can actually see
changes that are going on you can see
changes in the blood
so even though people aren't feeling
symptoms there can still be
physiological change but the proportion
of people that are completely
asymptomatic
is smaller than we did think at one time
john
great to get you on the show today john
campbell healthcare expert coming
through
carlisle in england thank you well some
blame young
people for the resurgence of the
coronavirus in germany they say
they're not sticking to social
distancing rules here's tessa
we are in the center of a possible
corona hotspot
berlin central this neighborhood popular
for its bars and nightlife is now seeing
a rise in infections
we asked around but most young people
didn't seem to be worried
some agreed to talk to us but want to
stay anonymous
are you scared to get infected well
no not at all don't think about it at
all
we just want to go out they said that a
second wave
would come so why would it be triggered
by people going out
we don't know how long time this corona
is going to last so
you can't just keep being scared like
yeah
all the time so infections in germany
are rising
and they're rising fast parties on the
street are a problem but bars and
restaurants are also in the spotlight
we're gonna check out this iconic bar
here in berlin but before we go in
i'm going to put on my mask
inside we see that germany's strict
hygiene measures are being upheld
people keep their distance and just like
greater mario kryber everyone wears a
face mask when moving around inside the
bar
customers are allowed to take it off
once seated at a table
but that seems to scare people off
tonight only a few guests are around
when coming in there are guests who say
next door i didn't have to wear a mask
why here then they turn around and leave
so my feeling is that as a bar you're
punished when you stick to the
regulations
another rule customers are required to
fill in these contact forms
with their name and telephone number but
that's also a problem
i can't believe that mr donald duck with
this weird address came to the spa
but look for yourself
the district of berlin wants to fight
the coronavirus by making more random
inspections now
but their resources are limited explains
the mayor
we can only do so much we have just
under 50 employees
they work and shift seven days a week
but we can't do more than just surprise
checks
the inspectors can't check every bar but
their presence
might remind people of just how serious
the situation has become
in the end things can only improve if
guests
show more responsibility
over to derek williams now our science
correspondent has been busy answering
your questions on the coronavirus
has there been any more research into
people catching covid19
twice this week researchers have for the
first time
reported three scientifically documented
cases
of people being reinfected with sars
cove
ii after having it once lots of
anecdotal cases have been reported
before
but this time the scientific evidence
that reinfection
really does occur is is strong because
the researchers say they sequence the
strains
that were isolated in the first and in
the second infections
and showed that they were genetically
distinct from one another
now it's important to note by the way
that that all of these claims
are unpublished and and still have to be
confirmed by
other scientists but but if they prove
true
uh what does it mean well an interesting
takeaway from me
is that one of the patients had classic
coveted symptoms uh the first time
around but was
asymptomatic when he tested positive the
second time around
which which could indicate that his
immune response
was keeping it under control so so
that's encouraging
but the fact that the tests were able to
detect
measurable levels of the virus in him
the second time around
also begs the question of whether people
who get
coveted 19 again could infect others
even if they're asymptomatic that we
don't know
most experts say that this development
while worrying
is not unexpected based on what we know
about our
immune response to coronaviruses in
general
almost no one expects acquired immunity
to sars cove 2
to be permanent but but until we have a
lot more evidence of this happening
to a lot more people the questions of if
and when people on average can be
reinfected
and and if they're infectious if they
catch it again
those questions remain pretty open
and a warning from the cdc with winter
coming in many parts of the world
here's director robert redfield a bad
flu season can really put certain
hospitals
into a
medical stress situation covet obviously
has that potential to be so important
with flu and covet come in at the same
time
that we really try to take flu off the
table as much as possible and
embracing the flu vaccine is one of the
most important things we can do